a venezuela la están aquejando
diferentes problemas pero cuál sería
desde el punto de vista de ustedes y de
acuerdo a lo que arrojó esta
investigación la causa que está
profundizando la pobreza en venezuela
muy buenas noches muchas gracias por
esta invitación
mira de acuerdo a lo que el estudio de
condiciones de vida señala con mucha
claridad el gran problema es la
reducción del empleo en venezuela
lamentablemente nosotros hemos perdido
en un año
21 puntos 8 puntos porcentuales
en la reducción del empleo formal
hoy en día en venezuela de la del total
de la fuerza
económicamente activa nosotros tenemos
algo así como 4.4 millones de empleos de
los cuales el 70% son del sector público
y el 30% del sector privado el otro
porcentaje que más o menos un
51% son trabajadores por cuenta propia
hacen lo que pueden como pueden donde
pueden y evidentemente eso genera una
total
y dificultad para la
desarrollo de la vida cotidiana señor
virtuoso así las cosas entonces queda un
5% de la sociedad venezolana que puede
mantener digámoslo de alguna manera su
nivel de ingresos a pesar de la
situación que está presentando el país
este 5% puede desaparecer y el país
pasar a pobreza extrema o ya tocó fondo
la sociedad venezolana
bueno nosotros creemos de acuerdo al
estudio que la pobreza de ingreso que
alcanza pues esa terrible y astronómica
cifra de aproximadamente un 90 y 4.5 por
ciento ya tocó fondo es decir
estamos hablando de pues casi la gran
mayoría de los venezolanos apenas un 5%
puede indexar con sus ingresos la
inflación acordémonos que venezuela está
viviendo una situación de hiperinflación
desde el año 2017 de tal manera que lo
más normal en una hiperinflación pues
que alcanza cifra astronómica es que
pues el ingreso de las familias no va
para poder vivir y por lo tanto esos son
los niveles que tiene el término
preguntándole tener una sociedad inmersa
en la pobreza trae repercusiones al
mediano y a largo plazo qué
consecuencias va a traer esto para
venezuela si mantiene esta tendencia de
la pobreza en su población y solamente
teniendo un 5% de la población logrando
mantenerse con sus ingresos
mira pues una población que vive en
situación de emergencia humanitaria
venezuela sigue viviendo una situación
de emergencia humanitaria que solo se
podrá resolver en la medida en que haya
un arreglo institucional
venezuela necesita generar confianza
para la inversión de capitales
nacionales y extranjeros venezuela
necesita generar confianza para que
otros estados puedan desarrollar
procesos de cooperación internacional en
distintos ámbitos venezuela necesita
generar confianza para que haya una
recomposición de las reglas de juego
institucional
el problema venezolano es un problema
económico y social pero su solución sólo
dependerá de un arreglo político
institucional y ponemos todas nuestras
esperanzas en este proceso de
negociación que se está desarrollando en
mente